five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
quarantine genius brain podcast we got
another special guest once again that
quarantine gets Cali boy you know I'm
sick because I keep six feet apart we've
been around each other since the
beginning a quarantine man yeah man yeah
man it's been rough uh it's [ __ ] like
a hundred degrees now in Pasadena it
went from 60 degrees in writing to about
100 degrees it's hot as [ __ ] yeah man it
stays out like 80 at midnight and 75 at
3:00 a.m. and it kicks right back up to
90 next morning I've been sending this
full these clips of this of one of my
favorite shows ever and actually got put
onto the show by Tim it's called 90 day
fiancé is the most irresponsible show
you will ever see in your [ __ ] life
and usually I don't like reality TV
shows yeah
like reality it's not my [ __ ] I think
it's just cuz of the times this is like
just what can't what else can you watch
is like deviate or go away from like
yeah it's mindless TV that I like yes
because I think sometimes like you know
we try to watch film or whatever
sometimes too heavy like I can't watch
that [ __ ] yeah but a fiance specifically
is only for this guy named big Edie
everybody knows who big [ __ ] ed is
Big Ed is his guy he has I think it's
something called like AFS or something
like that yeah yeah some kind of some
kind of syndrome so he has so now
initially when I was cracking jokes
about this fool I don't know that he had
a condition you didn't know yet in
conditions I just thought he was short
and fat because I know like short and
fat because look he just looks short and
fat you know true because people would
chaos at kfs if you guys see it if you
guys see Google that his his uh syndrome
up I don't know what let me look that
[ __ ] up I don't think it's called kfs I
feel like I'm [ __ ] it up I think it
is but it is it's called thick neck
syndrome so big I think because in my
elementary school that we had this kid
named Robert he was his black kid and he
hadn't identified and then like I
remember the teacher biasing because a
lot of us were picking on him I mean
like he has been different
we had a condition like we have to have
it yeah I know we got intervention I was
like oh [ __ ] I didn't know that cuz like
he kind of looked like big head we just
called him Humpty Dumpty
[Laughter]
how do you bully bully laughs I'm not
laughing to be fair he was a jackass
before we could be a jackass okay like
he had to overcompensate and it's not
his fault
yeah I'm just assuming cuz he was one
grade above and like I was a fifth
grader he's a 6th grader and like we had
that proper respect like okay cool but
every time you look like kickball like
he would kick that [ __ ] and then like
he's just like kind of like a do this
kind of thing like he cuz he because he
can't rotate her neck oh that's right
yes you have to physically move her but
like you know move your body so just
like seeing that was kind of like funny
and like go back to going back to Big Ed
like I remember I was watching this
interview Matthew told me to watch it he
was like it's so funny that this kid
came up to me after I became famous and
this kid saw me was like can I draw you
and biggie I was like yeah draw me cool
you're a kid you have you been
you're pure ya even know you know you
know and then she showed the picture and
it like had a box in another box this is
what the kid saw it's like that's just
so fun that's just how I look but then I
was you know become adults you make fun
of it dumby is a really good dish though
like as kids that's a pretty accurate
dish that's what I was like cracking up
about because when you said Humpty
Dumpty I imagine he pictured Big Ed but
here's the thing
Big Ed if you look at a picture of him
when he was younger it's not he looked
good yeah his kfs is not as as severe as
I think other peoples are because when
he when he was younger and he was fit it
just looked like he had a wrestlers neck
hmm I looked up pictures of KF k FS and
I know what that's the syndrome is or
the the bone disease and they have
because other people who have it is a
lot more severe like the kind of like
tilted over a little bit it's way
thicker so when he said he had KF s or I
didn't know what that wasn't I'll look
it up I'm like oh it's this this is the
thing that people at the ailment because
what happens is when k FS I guess like a
couple of your
they become fused so from C 1 through c5
I believe and I think a couple and
become few so they have limited movement
in their neck and they have a barrel
chest and they have a thicker neck but
his doesn't look that bad if he lost
weight cuz when he was younger he was a
stud
oh sure that yeah true that right cuz we
yeah it didn't look like probably your
friend that you saw in L know yeah he
did it
no I'm not no I'm not no it's so
interesting though because when you
watch 90-day fiance look like the Tim I
have to because he was mean he was a
bully okay whatever I mean a shout but
he was a bully too he just looked like
you know those aliens from Mars attack
alright go on so I started like digging
deep into the 90-day fiance thing did
you see the video the the Instagram live
of Rose talking about Big Ed nah she was
like uh she has an Instagram and she
went on IG live to talk [ __ ] about big N
and afterwards so basically throughout
this whole thing if you haven't seen the
90 day fiancé show they have 90-day
fiance abroad where basically the guys
or girl they go over to the other
country and they you know they try to
get married to this person they meet
them up or whatever so big head mate
metros in the Philippines and she lives
in a very very very rural area the
Philippines like [ __ ] I'm talking about
tin roof electrical wiring everywhere
when you take a shower you see the
chickens right next to Nana [ __ ] and eat
the mouse she was talking about how like
on the show like Edie was constantly
disrespectful towards which people did
see on the show he was disrespectful
towards her he only cared about Fame and
he never really cared about her so she's
kind of outing him out saying that he
only came on the show to be famous and
he didn't really actually love her and
so she just started blasting him on his
life which I was kind of shocked and a
lot of people on the comments on the IG
live agreed yeah because there's a few
moments on the show where he was pretty
[ __ ] disrespectful like yeah
number one he talked he well get asking
your partner to get an STD test I don't
think his disrespect close how he went
about it right cuz he should if he's
gonna ask if I'm hurt he should get one
too
mm-hm right and you're right
so but obviously you know probably the
way he looks as his STD check it away
anyways yeah I mean this he hadn't been
in a relationship like 28 years or
something well since his divorce mmm and
the dating has been really difficult for
him it night it's just funny that he's
been so aware that he might has he might
have that assumption about overseas yeah
exactly so you're like you know you've
been [ __ ] around a little bit and you
definitely have an STD right yes sir to
shave her legs you don't like her her
legs she did you see the part where he
asked her to [ __ ] you give her mouth
watching a toothpick oh yeah I just saw
that clip yesterday that was so bad he's
like well I don't think she knows that
maybe her breath is that you know black
could cause heart disease come on bro so
he gift first of all the creepiest thing
ever is that he first gifted her with
lingerie hmm already creepy you know you
just met her for the first time and then
he gives her with mouthwash and
toothpaste and then she finds out that
her bad breath isn't from her teeth
because if you look at her teeth and her
gums
she's great teeth unless she brushes her
teeth all the time she even says like I
brush my teeth I actually have a an
ulcer no that's where that Cassidy it's
coming from it's like to be ulcer in her
stomach which I've had an ulcer and that
[ __ ] is because I love like acid in your
gut or a smell that [ __ ] mm-hmm so she
was super offended by that so he's
basically he kind of talks to her if you
see on the show like she's for lack of a
better word [ __ ]
yeah he talks to her like she's a like
she said yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] and she
comes back pretty well-informed yeah
every time so like it'd be keeps doing
that over and over like a language
barrier is not that it's not a
reflection of intelligence I thought I
mean it's like well she's funny like
sometimes she'll react in this situation
she like ed is like the oddball in the
situation and she like makes these
little jokes that we would make the
little G yeah and there's no language
barrier there so like big and it man I
didn't know she wanted ID you live to
talk about how yeah how you might have
manipulated a narrative
well I kind of got also this show
because you saw the that that morning
show where he was interviewed where he
was being interviewed about the stuff
right and the whole interview was
basically about how famous he is now
right right you know he's just stickers
and he's like I have a sticker everybody
has a sticker it's like it's a sticker
my dog has a sticker saying what the
[ __ ] wrote like relax man like you could
now it makes that ID live a lot more
believable that he was kind of in it
just for the fame right right because
you didn't really treat her respectfully
and mind you like the stuff that you see
on the show is [ __ ] hilarious like
earlier I did a reference about the eat
the mouse I guess the the dad asked II D
to take a shower to get us that they do
cuz after a night of like the torrential
downpour of rain and like the bed being
flooded the neck didn't go sleep and
she's making fun of him for that and it
makes me think about like Danone
narrative goes back and forth because he
said he set his like special sheets
mm-hmm to that to the Philippines so
that it would like peas or his skin
conditioner yeah what if he has but they
never arrived
it makes me think like maybe they just
sold that [ __ ] yeah so that's the
narrative I was rolling with now I'm
like neither you telling me this I don't
know what to think
who knows because he was saying that he
was sending but he sent like five
thousand dollars worth the gifts to her
yeah and none of that [ __ ] arrived but
then it's five hours away from Manila
yeah yeah who [ __ ] know they had to
take this shower and it's the funniest
[ __ ] scene because I don't think he
realized like first of all like the
Philippines the rural area is pretty
pretty bad right here in world man and
I've never been to the Philippines but
I'm saying this from Filipino friends
who told me about the rule areas the
Philippines like it's still really bad
up and when you don't have like people
live really rich or they live really
poor right just how a lot of these Asian
countries and so he's taking a shower
this book first of all how he's reacting
they take a shower and they go he goes
are those chickens like a chicken coop
right over here I think instead that you
get shower there's this [ __ ] mangy
little rat and it's like Master Splinter
if I even move it's like yeah it's so
old it's like the oldest rat ever
like chilling on his slippers Yeah right
and he goes is that a rat and she goes I
eat the mouse eat the mouse I think it's
a mouse she was like it was a rat I'd
maybe she starts clowning on him cuz
she's like oh what that baby yeah baby
yeah cuz her reality of what she lives
in is just her every day and then what
he expected was something completely
different
hmm it was kind of crazy when I saw that
[ __ ] but her living conditions her
living edition right because it also
like see cuz I've never seen it now it's
the first time I've seen like these
really harsh conditions and it makes me
think about like my best friend Mark who
hid they had like this Exodus were like
10 of his relatives like flew over they
put them up in his home in complex in
our apartment complex is a 2-bedroom
with like 10 people damn
so people two people were sleeping in
the tub people sleeping on the bottom of
the the kitchens people are like a bunch
of people in both bedrooms I'm like man
this is crazy and every time they would
ask me like can we borrow your weight
scale and yeah yeah is I guess I was
like a common things you have to wait
that thing and my sin dollars [ __ ] back
to the Philippines on my mantises you
know when we go to like even when we my
mom used to gift basic stuff to like
people in Korea and because USA made
stuff is more regulated than it is like
in Asia in China so for example they
would ask us to send them like centrum
from Costco yeah [ __ ] centrum things
like [ __ ] yeah
it's weird I didn't I've seen I was like
this mad boy yeah it was like like basic
[ __ ] like said some Pedialyte all this
other random visa and it was because
they don't trust like the stuff that
they get from China they said like the
stuff from China or whatever is made in
Asia is regulated and it's pretty bad
and they want American brand stuff so my
mom was said like [ __ ] Flintstone
vitamins and [ __ ] like what they don't
want this [ __ ] yeah my mom's I know this
is the stuff that they want so they
would have to package like suitcases
full of stuff in Korea we had to fill
that [ __ ] up and bring it over yeah he
would come over like every other week
say don't daddy bleep can I use your
weights girl I'm a DAB you like no you
can't use
you had your Herbert no you can't my mom
was like Oh take it take it just call
ahead yeah I know the situation yeah so
funny man I mean we're like what the
[ __ ] what's it called when they were
he didn't last in that area for too long
because remember he also has a skin
condition where he's in some kind of
dermatitis yeah and then Oh [ __ ] he
had to sleep on the floor with his
clothes and there was a scene the way
that the Edit the show is [ __ ] funny
like that he goes my bats grind yes I
mean it was a moment and he slept with
his head on the wall well and then they
went to the pig farm the piggy farm the
pig farm would you fire me because
dropping the football oh [ __ ] I'm so
sorry expect when you put plastic bags
on your shoes bro like just wrap it up
and wrap it up and let it go yeah yeah
yeah you buy some new shoes
I didn't the [ __ ] crazy thing was the
dead six right next to the [ __ ] pig
yeah dude with the with the cargo slash
it just sleeps right next to him yeah
this [ __ ] insane have you as funny
have you seen any other of the other
episodes with I mean I'm caught up bro I
mean I guess the next episode comes out
tomorrow did you see in this season who
they had they have Big Ed they have bad
Big Ed I don't know their names they had
loose mon loose mind Lisa may be a girl
baby love baby love she's [ __ ] mean
dude she's really mean she's [ __ ]
mean to that yeah yeah I get the amount
of disrespect she has towards him is
unfuckin so funny because she treats him
like the sir typical assumption you
would have about a Nigerian yeah yeah
he's like the sweetest trust me
yeah why don't you trust me yeah there
at that and then there's just other
episode that I saw where
I was telling you about this but it's
the it's the it's the guy his name is
Caesar hmm and Caesar is in love with
basically this this Russian catfisher
and he doesn't understand that he's
being played and he's so madly in love
with her because she's very [ __ ]
beautiful she's like the the classic
blond-haired blue-eyed russian girl that
you would think from as a call girl or
whatever and clearly she's not
interested in him and one of the first
things that they asked like the camera
person asked they go
because well she sends me video says she
loves me she goes hello my husband I I
miss you very much and she goes has she
ever said your name in those videos and
he goes no it's just generic stare she
definitely has a few guys that she's
sending this out to right but he doesn't
believe it he just isn't madly in love
with her he thinks that he is the only
one for her they've been together for
five years when he says and they had a
mediation where when the show was done
this was probably a previous season
where she came up on a video thing and
he goes we've been together for five
years she goes we've been together for
about two get out like all the
information isn't working together and
he's like well I'm just gonna call it
off and she's like call what off
basically we have nearly oh did you love
she goes I love Kim that's I love him
that's so sad
he said it about like four grand a month
or some [ __ ] like that - that's so sad
that cut yeah I can't have you been
catfished hell no dude well when I
remember like Craigslist back in the day
so there was that scam where if you send
me a thousand dollars or whatever I
almost did that [ __ ] well super super
young mob why were you by I was buying
an mp3 player okay and then oh I think I
know why he's like the carding or the
carding yeah yeah fake because you
didn't even need like hmm yeah so I
almost did that [ __ ] and I didn't last
minute I was like this is a little fishy
I don't get this [ __ ] and I kind of and
I stopped doing it and then after a
while like I got another email from the
same Duty is like okay well how about
this like I'll send you the mp3 just
keep it he goes I just need you send me
a thousand dollars and I'll send you ten
thousand you know all the other [ __ ] and
I was like oh my god this is getting
ridiculous and I told him as how about
this how about I send you five dollars
and then you said we started going back
before that after a while you tell you
get fed up I'm just [ __ ] around with
him but people used to get catfished a
lot like I think the the the
telemarketer calls and it it they still
do it because it works on old people
yeah totally old people get scan all the
[ __ ] because it only work computers
and they're no they don't remove from
that it reminds me of like this woman
who works at or who lives in my boss is
a complex and she got this she was like
super
scared and came over as IQ where's your
boss Adam like he's next door he's like
okay she goes over there and then I hear
the conversation she like is this email
saying like I need you need to save me
like $5,000 worth of like Target Gift
Cards or else they'll give up my social
security number which they got and so
she did she went to Target and like did
that she's like what the [ __ ] you were
like 45 dude Oh buddy Alex told me too
that he knew somebody who it was their
grandparents or parents who sent a
random person like five thousand dollars
because they said that their son was in
the hospital and they don't operate on
him unless they give them I was like
what is a hospital
ever done that right you're an adult
right the hospital will operate first
and then they send you a bill after
right when had they ever said no we're
not gonna do so she fails all people we
failed that makes absolute on my [ __ ]
old people a new workshop like not how
to get skin I'm gonna go all over the
country like do you not get scammed you
know what I was so shocked at recently
because the off the often trend is that
a lot of old people are saying that the
younger generation are it's very soft
and a weak and very brittle right but
Ovid is actually proving the other way
around where all these old people are
the ones that are a little soft and a
little brittle and a little weak when it
comes to stuff that they can't do
anymore right and I think that shows
like that weird perspective flip because
there's this there's this group
specifically in South Pasadena there's a
group of older people what they have a
group called a Cobra it is like free
like open 19:03 Cove in 19 or something
like that right or some kind of
revolution and they are partying and
they're getting together the in spite of
COBIT saying that their their freedom is
being stripped right so if you look up
online right now there's a couple of
clips of people talking about number one
Cobin 19 is the the quarantine is
basically a for slavery that's it's
crazy that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] wild
they're comparing doing a quarantine to
slavery they're saying that they're
their natural rights and their freedom
is being stripped right and I think I
understand to a certain extent where
yeah it's kind of tough that we're not
allowed to do this stuff
we're normally supposed to do right and
you know they're quoting the
Constitution or whatever our natural
rights but that's not pending on
depending on if it's like like a
national disaster or something like that
that's when things switch up a little
bit all right
but at this point to has only been a
[ __ ] month like it just hit a month
recently yeah and people already flip
for us yeah I mean just you just can't
tell Americans they can't do [ __ ] yeah
it's just tell American to do it yeah I
think everybody in and all the other
countries are like okay cool well yes
I'm thinking cuz like what how are other
countries handling this like it's
hitting their economies I'm sure mm-hmm
obviously but I haven't heard stories
that like we need to open up the economy
again like I saw essential businesses
and like trying to you know
differentiate what is essential what so
what is yeah because I understand to a
certain extent because a lot of
businesses have closed down and so we
have to worry about a common we have to
find a perfect medium right because we
can't always live in this perpetual fear
of having them I mean the main issue is
that we don't have a vaccine right so if
people kind of read and they do their
research I mean who knows how much if
this is true or not right but people are
comparing the Cova to the flu right
which is a false comparison because
number one the flu has a vaccine mm-hmm
so we're not even worried about it right
we were still learning more about it
exactly we don't know anything about
kovat right now Koba 19 specific
regional II when it first came out when
we did this podcast we talked about oh
it'll live on cardboard for an hour and
apparently that's not true
down your stuff anymore it's like what
the [ __ ] did I just read that like oh
you know younger people and under 40 are
more prone to be asymptomatic to it but
the people who have contracted the virus
they can be healthy enough to bypass the
the repercussions you would get from the
lungs infections the lungs but it will
later on for them into clots and so
they're finding more younger people
getting strokes yeah this is conveyed
that's crazy so my best friend gobble
actually told me about this when we were
talking on the phone where he was
talking about like Cove it has like a
propensity as a blood coagulant like
that why it's causing these strokes
right so but the crazy thing is and what
people don't understand and they're like
well they're making comparisons to the
flu or what
the reason why these comparisons don't
make sense because we understand the flu
right we understand that virus and there
is a vaccine for it there is no vaccine
for this and they're still finding
things out about this over and kind of
ignore we let it do its run its course
it's not the same and they talk about
well you know people get the flu every
year it's a seasonal thing you're still
making in a false comparison because of
how the infectious rate of kovat is like
ten times higher than the flu like this
is not conspiracy this is just facts
right like I don't remember the exact
term but like how fast and how quickly
you can get Kovac versus the flu is like
times 10 or some [ __ ] like that so
they're making this comparison of like
Oh only this amount of people died from
it but we don't know enough about the
virus right now which is why we're
trying to make sure people don't do this
going out of shape and so people can
figure it out first get a vaccine and
then move on alright they were making
this comparison about it too in Sweden I
guess they're trying to do something
called herd immunity and you guys could
read an article about it right the the
heard him I guess they're allowing
people of a certain amount of groups of
people to stay so it's like I think I
was like 25 or sumption you guys could
fact check me on that but it was they're
allowing people to hang out in groups
again but it's still a limited number
and they're doing herd immunity and so I
just saw a couple people on Facebook
post this [ __ ] that like see this is
what we need to do I read the article so
the article says that they're allowing
they're not allowing just people just to
go in whatever large groups that they
want they're allowing young people to do
it they're getting hurt immunity and the
curb is dying a little faster right
however they have the highest mortality
rate in older people so old people are
dying left and right murder so there
that's the problem
rights and the like the numbers aren't
completely accurate but they do have a
very very high mortality rate with their
elderly population compared to
everywhere else in the world so yeah so
for us we're saying that we're trying to
watch everybody's back we want our elder
people to live so we're trying to be a
little more mindful yeah you could do a
Sweden is doing but California or in
like certain parts in the United States
or we're doing a very good job in terms
of life mortality to how many cases
there are right because we're being
mindful of this the other things if
we're like [ __ ] it let's just get it and
live and let these old people die then
fine whatever
right but people get these hot takes of
these articles they don't even read the
whole [ __ ] article and they they're
just posting it on Facebook yeah it's
not really going deep into the article
yeah because the the
who posted wrote like see like this is
how Sweden is doing and I read the
article is like you didn't read the
article mmm they said that their elder
population is dying they still don't
know how to figure this out but it's
it's it's still a very risky thing to do
and the more safety to do is to do
social distancing and it's the herd
immunity thing I've heard recently I
don't know if it's the thing with Vegas
I'm here about Vegas and other so my
friend John or whatever he lives in
Vegas he's like this is what it looks
like it's like a post-apocalyptic
there's like no taxis yeah no people
passing out titty cards 2d cards yeah no
I should and the mayor now wants or the
governor the mayor wants to reopen the
business of casinos and give her a like
why do you want to do that we haven't
even planned the curve yet hmm it's like
well we I'm willing to practice opening
it up and basically what she was saying
is like I don't mind my people to be the
control group for herd immunity for
immunity yeah that's all crazy so like
whatever happens happens like we want to
show that it's better now so let me open
up my casinos get business going back up
and just see what the met with this
would be the worst place to do it worse
place so many groups of people number
two very old population their budget is
smokin and a [ __ ] ton of smokers yeah
they're the worst people to start this
off insulated oh that should hurt Alaska
doesn't have any cases of co-ed though
really yeah Alaska is like no cases of
covert or some [ __ ] like [ __ ] or maybe I
might be confused that we're no no cases
of deaths or some show yeah which is
which is very [ __ ] interesting and
then all the prisons have co-ed which I
which blew my [ __ ] mind that Kobe was
in prisons I guess it has to come from
visitors and the guards and stuff like
that right but they don't have any like
better protection stuff you said
something [ __ ] about what like there was
like a judge that released a bunch of
like minor oh yeah so that new while a
music video I don't know I wish I knew I
think as a Rikers Island
maybe maybe three words under the Care
Act yeah very lucky if you have no if
you're not in jail do you know the Care
Act no I look it up
know what it was but if it's just if
you're in there for a petty reason yeah
then the this judge want so basically
his judge saw this music feel about wale
called Sumi and at the end of this music
video while he puts this prisoner in
there and he's talking about the
situation inside
I think it's Rikers or was some prison
he's coasts saying like there's no
attention no medical attention given to
these prisoners they're all in this very
enclosed space Hema shows like a video
of one of his bunk mates who obviously
has difficulty breathing and he's like
right you can't even move you know and
then he's like I don't know how they
have cell phones and the prisons to
begin with but he like flips the phone
around and shows out in the distance on
the and the other side of the cliff or
whatever like this big-ass bunker full
of people who have covin yeah he's
saying like they don't give a [ __ ] about
us
people are dying that's where people are
dying over there I am in for like a
petty reason and I so I have one year
left or like six months left I may not
even get to get to be at because they're
not taking care of us in here in kovat
so judge saw it and then wanted to find
out who he was and who or whoever else
was under the Care Act to be released
damn that's crazy yeah from a music
video a music video yeah it's it's weird
when I see I just never thought that it
would affect the presence like that but
I guess it makes sense because it's in a
confined space dude I'll be [ __ ]
scared shitless if I'm in a prison and
my [ __ ] roommate my bunkmate has
kovat and I just got his chill there mmm
that's [ __ ] frightening as hell dude
yeah I can't I can't do prison I'll I'll
die in prison man I'm not one of those
people that would survive that [ __ ] you
know me for it huh you know me for it no
I'd be a [ __ ] in the first about the
first day he's got one movie with Adam
Sandler what's it called the the remake
that he did that one film where he went
to prison he was a football player
remember Tracy morning was a gay
cheerleader
you remember that The Longest Yard hey
watch that you never saw a long [ __ ]
funny I think I said any given Sunday
but he was
no it was the Longest Yard is where like
Tracy pocket so [ __ ] gay cheerleader
this was like sucking people I'll be
tracing what about this when we were
talking about 90-day fiance we were also
having a conversation about like the
times like people have been bullied or
or how many times people have been
bullied in their lives and the funny
thing is like when I look back at
[ __ ] bullying mm-hmm
I can I can almost account recount every
time to somebody try to bully me like I
can almost remember it like it was
[ __ ] yesterday like me we were
talking about remember back in the day
they used to do that [ __ ] called flat
tires and so they that's when somebody
would walk behind you and they would
step on your shoe hmm causing your chute
you know [ __ ] you know come out of
your shoe mmm I hate that [ __ ] and
there's his kid call him MJ his name was
Michael Jordan shittiest person did that
ever play basketball not Michael
this guy Gordon [ __ ] suck the
basketball maxine kid okay full Kip on
flat tire hello Mexican kid named
Michael Jordan alright go ahead that was
cop that was a cop and then he kept on
flat tiring my shoe and mind you I was
like a new kid in the school so when I
was in third grade I got removed from
that school from you know too much
violent [ __ ] and then I went to a
different school called Isabel Jackson
school so Isabel Jackson Elementary I
went there and I was like the little odd
kid out right like I you know I didn't
really [ __ ] know anybody and
obviously when that first kid comes in
specifically the way I looked I was
ready for the ready to get bullied but
there's this kid was already a dweeb and
when a dweeb tries to bully me it's like
this the last person that's gonna
[ __ ] bully me you know I mean but I
remember he came off flat tiring the the
back of my shoe and I kept on telling
him stop doing it and I in my mind I
always said this fail and get three
warnings some three warnings three
warnings and that means that I just got
to start swinging because I just hated
getting bullied and so this kid who is
already somebody who got bullied is
trying to bully some other kid just like
who the [ __ ] do you think you are man we
in the same team like we're were the
ones that get bullied you try to bully
me like what the [ __ ] was supposed to
rise up yeah this guy
kept on doing it on the third one I just
turned him out I socked him right in the
solar plex was like blaow right in the
I remember that [ __ ] because I only
remember to punch somebody right there's
because this other kid named Brian in
the previous school that I was in
sucker-punched me and he hit me right in
the middle and I remember getting
punched the sole places and losing all
my air so although I remember this [ __ ]
now I know where to sock people yeah I
turned around no questions asked and I
said [ __ ] gut and then he got all the
wind knocked out him he started gasping
for air just crying and then I think her
name was Miss Gil consent she grabbed me
and just started dragging me to be
honest and just [ __ ] threw me in
there with no questions asked I hated
getting bully but I love shocking people
for it though nice [ __ ] man I definitely
knew him yeah I mean like because i'm so
athlei ambiguous and like my elementary
school is predominantly mexican mm-hmm I
could chameleon and yeah Mexican I think
what I got bullied for thinking back on
it now is is I was one of the first
people to adhere to the the clothing
restrictions of like uniforms hmm so the
Dickies and the you know it's tough and
like it was like loosely required but it
was cheap and my parents made me wear it
and so whenever I would wear it I had
like the high floods yeah
those my socks had like the shittiest
shoes and I remember just being Punk'd
for that but I wouldn't put myself in
situations to get bullied I was always
on the basketball court I mean that's
when I was serving it yeah yeah I was
always out there so I wasn't oh you
wouldn't catch me down the hallway you
wouldn't catch me at a table away from
anybody else I think that's where most
of the bullying happens yeah I remember
kids taking like matcha lupa like your
chalupa cuz that [ __ ] was the bomb
pretty much yeah I don't
yeah I'd never yeah it really wasn't I
had that I was fortunate enough to like
be in certain circles and then having
friends who were older and like there
wasn't that [ __ ] neighbor prevent that
[ __ ] for me and so I rarely everytime I
would find myself in a situation where
like oh [ __ ] I'm about to get my ass
jumped or kicked or who knows what like
my older homie
would know that person and be like y'all
he's cool yeah oh he's cool he's cool I
was like who's [ __ ] with you all
right hold up yeah and it goes you know
go do the business that's weird because
I feel like in my school it wasn't there
wasn't so much bullying going on from
what I remember cuz when I was in high
school I didn't get bullied right hmm I
mean it didn't happen much I kind of
just I felt like in my school if you
mind your own business you were pretty
good yeah but then when you stuck your
neck out is that's when people would try
to chop at you a little bit right like
there was this kid named Nader we're
talking about this kid this kid Nader
was like one of those dudes that for
sure in high school he wanted to let
other people know that he was smarter
than them right so he was that kid in
school like if everybody if the teacher
forgot to collect homework he goes hold
on oh [ __ ] yeah yeah you forgot to
collect our homework about to get [ __ ]
up dude yeah and so people would [ __ ]
his ass up because he will ruin it for
everybody else and then he would always
do [ __ ] like his favorite phrase was
[ __ ] actually even like well actually
and he would constantly either interrupt
the teacher or you interrupt somebody
else to let them know that he's smarter
than which he wasn't even that smart
he was his grades were whatever it's
like you've dumb you're just as dumb as
everybody out the [ __ ] up right but he
would always get his ass beat and he
would you know he would kind of play
victim but it's like nobody's really
telling you to [ __ ] talk this much
like if you would just shut the [ __ ] up
people want to stop your face how do you
just shut the [ __ ] up that kind of
triggered me a little bit only because
in pre-algebra I was flunking class and
I was on like the I was in my chances of
playing for the team for basketball team
was in jeopardy and so my dad was
tutoring me and he would not let me go
to sleep until like I would do my
homework and then do extra homework like
he asked my teacher for like extra
problems and like made sure I understood
the lessons of that week so that when
the test came around I would pass that
and I remember it was like a mix of all
sorts of people on my grade I
in my class and I like studied my ass
off like my dad did like sleep
deprivation yeah and I remember I just
[ __ ] obliterated the curve like I said
I I think the highest you could get was
like a hundred mm and I got like a
hundred and twenty-five like the
extra-credit like a hundred twenty-five
the average in that class was like 60
big I literally failed everybody in my
class as a teacher yes I remember people
being like what the [ __ ] man like cuz I
would make sure like if I did the
homework she collected it mrs. Swan yeah
you I was like actually I forgot to
collect the extra homework and here's
extra credit and this and this and that
and I remember like the upperclassman
who failed and we're in pre-algebra
we're like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you up
but then I would tell mark or Peter and
like yeah like I'll be safe I need to
get on the basketball team I'm failing
dude I need this [ __ ] I'm the person you
think in an all predominantly Asian high
school cuz I'm you know from seven
twelve is like a thousand students and
the majority people were Asian like you
would assume your black kid yeah that's
black kid would fail and I'm are good
but and then I'm the last person that's
[ __ ] funny they like bust occur yeah
they probably they got their ass beat at
home for they were like actually the
highest score on the test like the
possibly like the average was 65 the
highest score was 125 and like who the
[ __ ] got that [ __ ] and I was like oh
[ __ ] oh and mrs. wah was like good job I
was like we just looked at me as oh [ __ ]
yeah that's [ __ ] funny I've never
been at the top of a curve nothing dude
that was my first and only time oh yeah
that crazy though like when you really
do study though how well you can do more
yeah he's like you have the potential
could you do this now was with me and
the SATs like so when I when I did the
SATs I got a really really good score
and then like my school's not really
known for its academia right a lot of my
friends who gone into really great
colleges their their SAT scores weren't
anywhere near mine mmm they just were
very good at the grade part so following
the instructions really well I my
parents used to take me this thing
called really it was SAT schools they
used to always send the helo cream
yeah yeah me being the smart I said I
hated that [ __ ] didn't study for it at
all listen you went to the schools I saw
my cousin would I would go with my
cousin huh and then after my cousin
graduated I still had to take SAT school
still my my best friend Cabo used to
take me to SAT schools but what I would
do is I would get there and then teacher
Mike would go into the his office and
when he went to the office every time he
went to the office I would move the time
or five minutes so the class would only
end up being about like thirty five
minutes and then we would leave and then
he only found out about it like towards
like I think like the last couple weeks
he's like I have I been letting you guys
out early I might not like we got it
yeah I didn't study for that [ __ ] at all
but then I did really well in the SATs
because I just took the pre SAT book and
I just went over it like seven times and
then when I when I got my SAT scores
my dad was happy but he was [ __ ]
pissed and then he beat my ass because
he said that he only only proved how
lazy I am asked me for doing well yeah
so he was pissed that I I did well on
the SATs because I could have done that
well in school but I chose not to hmm
but hey to school I [ __ ] hated school
did your dad believe you what did your
dad bully you I'm pretty sure he bullied
yeah well I mean I put it like this and
I mentioned this before on a podcast so
it's so different when we talk about
parenting styles and what money and
poverty have a big influence on
parenting style is what I believe
right so when I went to college I
remember having a conversation with a
couple of my friends that uh that I met
over there well they were talking about
how they were punished right they would
get sent to their room their parents
would chastise them or whatever right
and I was like well how the [ __ ] did
your parents have time to do that [ __ ]
right my parents didn't have time for
that [ __ ] all right like if I [ __ ] up
they would correct that behavior quick
what the [ __ ] is socked in the face I'm
like okay maybe I shouldn't do this
anymore and I think a lot of the times
people forget that you know number one
our parents are only an extension of
their parents and they try to correct
certain bad behaviors and they saw that
their parents do but they still have you
know remnants of that also - is how much
time that my parents have to sit there
and talk to me for 30-40 minutes and
explain something to me yeah or do they
have to beat my ass real quick
get it done so they have to go back to
work and make some damn money mm-hmm so
but I think my dad definitely did the
best that he could and I think my mom
did the best that she could to with the
allot of time and money that they had
because I specifically remember when
they started making more money how much
nicer they were like they were still
[ __ ] harsh but though when we were
stressed out the most with money is when
my parents fought the most is when my
dad used to beat me the most it was
because they were just stressed out
my mom's have a [ __ ] psychopath hmm
so he had to deal with her yeah with my
[ __ ] ass getting two fights all the
time is right in elementary school all
the way to junior high and sometimes
even in high school so it was like okay
where do I have time to be a parent and
where do I have time to [ __ ] talk to
my kids so when I feel like it at the
moment at the moment I felt like my dad
was bullying me but at the same time now
it as an adult I look back and I say
he's probably just doing the best that
he could with what he had you know yeah
it's crazy it's sucks that so is it was
there inherently the inherent value of
that because it makes me think like so
made you better for it I guess would you
say because it makes it sound like it
makes me think about like my dad saying
like oh I see LeBron James she was a
single fault you know you know single
mother and look at him oh my why are you
telling me this he's like you could have
been now it's like what were you talking
about yeah so it makes me it feels like
we've come from the 90s where that
bullying is crazy now it's like the
cyber bullying but back then like we're
better for it and so it makes it sound
like like war vets yeah you know I think
be the the type of upbringing that I had
definitely because I survived it I feel
like I'm better equipped for it right
right so even when it comes to
cyberbullying right which I have to deal
with all the time like it and sometimes
too it's like you know because of
quarantine I have a lot more time for it
so now I'm just responding back to
people all day there's no personal
feelings into it it's just more like
okay well let's see if I could debate
this person you know but now it's like I
feel like if I didn't go through that if
I didn't go through an actual hardship
phase and I was put into YouTube now I
think I would have crumbled because I'd
be too weak too susceptible to people's
perception of Who I am right but I think
because I was younger and we did go
through the whole bullying phase of
other people right -
you know cyber bullying and [ __ ] and
then you know people trying to beat us
up jump us whatever alright I don't feel
like the stuff that phases me only
phases me a little bit compared to how
other people deal with it totally yeah
cuz the way I see some some other people
deal with stuff and they tell me about
their problems it sounds dumb to me
that's like yeah it hurts your feelings
why you dwelling on it so hard yeah yeah
totally yeah I don't know why I'm
thinking about that that quote quote bro
I don't know if it's Buddha or Nelson
Mandela's like saying like if you hold
on to a garage it's like drinking poison
expect another person to die mm-hmm
that's just diet yeah that is what it is
that's exactly because it eats away at
you so much Muriel and I got into a
little argument the other day and I
literally felt like I was getting kovat
because I was mad I was like oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] up my immune
system dude I'm so upset right like I
got so upset at her like I didn't
there was no yelling it was more like
you made me mad mm-hmm and then I I went
into the car I was in the car for like
three [ __ ] hours came back inside
couldn't even look at her I was so upset
until she apologized right right and
went upstairs and that day I started
feeling like sick like oh [ __ ] I think I
got Coby because anger is like [ __ ]
up my immune go get the mom and her baby
yeah and then she's like okay I'm sorry
and then I started feeling better yeah
and that's what it feels like we didn't
hold these grudges it starts to eat away
at you that's why some people don't
understand when you say when you
apologize to somebody or you forgive
somebody you're not really giving in to
what they want you're actually healing
yourself right when you forgive somebody
it's a gift to yourself saying I'm gonna
let your [ __ ] go yeah and I'm gonna
move on yeah cuz that's that's the hard
part like when some people like I know a
friend to where she still holds on to
stuff that happened in like elementary
school to her right so when she talks
about her past experiences it feels like
it was just yesterday
damn and a toy store like she doesn't
[ __ ] read and man and I'm like
happened when you were four [ __ ] all
right
like yeah yeah that's really a fashion
that she feels that way I mean it's just
so crazy that you during from Kate from
kindergarten to 12 we spend most of time
with their peers and we're trying to
figure this [ __ ] out and our parents are
busy doing their own things and now we
have to make sense of it 20 years later
and be like oh that's what was going
like is that a ongoing cycle I think
we're more informed now European stuff
like that because it's like it's
thinkorswim like if it doesn't kill you
makes you stronger but now it's like no
it's killing people like kids are like
hanging themselves a suicide like we
have talked about like is it the school
systems responsibility to have that
oversight is or are they just trying to
get this money to make sure there's
seats are filled in and get money from
the government or like whose
responsibility is it you know because it
makes us better in the end yeah but but
during that time is hard and some kids
are unfortunate that we do make it you
know I feel like some people talk about
it like it's natural selection is like
either you're made of Survivor you're
not that's so [ __ ] up yeah it is yeah
cuz we're we were strong we're fortunate
enough but so and so like they call it
they get called a [ __ ] and I'm like
what the [ __ ] I'm out of [ __ ]
yeah like thinking about that like this
kid when I Joshua was in my apartment
complex we would take shopping carts and
like ride them down the water ditch
that's the most Helda creek oh [ __ ] ours
is like and uh what was I forgot Carson
Street yeah go down that thing and it's
like either do that or get a surfboard
from Thrifty's or save on whatever and
like wax the staircase and like just
launch down yeah and like boogie board
down the staircase and if you didn't do
that you were a [ __ ] yeah you know and
other kids I'm like I'm gonna do it
thank God I didn't [ __ ] break a bone
or anything I did like get slammed into
a pole yeah but whatever I've survived
but other people they're like I'm not
gonna do that it's like if I can't do
this I'm a [ __ ] I'm weak
natural selection I'm not strong enough
I'm gonna surround myself yeah I mean
it's weird like I think I think the
constant when I talk about bullying too
sometimes when people say like we're
gonna eliminate bullying I think you're
dumb like that's not gonna it's just
buildings like I have it's like a crazy
for criticism
yeah bullying happens in [ __ ] animals
like a jungle like creatures bully each
other all the time it's inherently in us
- for some reason for a lot of people to
want to pick on the weak right and what
what I really attribute bullying
is a weakness in the individual and they
sniff it out in somebody else because
they see that same quality in themselves
right it makes them feel stronger that
they could loom over this other person
because there's something that's going
on in their personal life it sounds like
some kind of hippie-dippie [ __ ] but
it is really true because I talked about
the story the first time I tried
bullying somebody and I felt like [ __ ]
after because I wanted to know what it
felt like to bully somebody else right I
wanted to be the bully because if I was
going to be bullied then I want to be on
the other side of when I did it I felt
like trash so I never really did it
again right David you have empathy but
because if if we even look even deeper
than that people don't even realize why
a lot of these like Asian gangs formed
back in the day like a lot of these
immigrant gangs formed because they were
told that they didn't belong in this
country they were bullied because of
their food the way that they spoke the
way then they dressed how they were who
they were what they were eating
everything right so they formed these
gangs to say if you [ __ ] with me I will
[ __ ] you up like I will kill you and
we're gonna be bigger than you we have
bigger numbers we're stronger and we're
[ __ ] crazy or Asian boys watching
exactly that's how you get these [ __ ]
and these people to like specifically
the Southeast Asian gangs they came from
war-torn countries watching their family
get murdered shot much at day to death
so your little comments about their face
didn't [ __ ] matter they would chop
you at your [ __ ] knees like so when
we talk about bullying right it's this
weird thing of insecure people trying to
make other people feel just as bad as
they feel about themselves oh yeah and
that's that's the hard part right and so
what is that when we go back to your
conversation about having people heal is
who does is responsibility lion I'm
making these people you know either
process what's going on in their head in
terms of how they feel about themselves
about other people bullying them or do
we have this responsibility to dump on
the parent because what happens to and
what people are finding out during the
coab is situation is that you're only a
parent after 4 or 5 p.m. yeah because
the other parents are actually the
teachers mmm right they are actually the
biggest influences on your kids during
the time that you're gone especially in
elementary school they're the ones
talking to your kids talking out their
problems and feelings
and then you get your kid after 3 p.m.
and then you're supposed to figure out
what they went through from 7-8 6 to 7
a.m. all the way to 3 p.m. to 2 p.m.
right because I want to talk about that
time yeah they want decompress and [ __ ]
how was your day so I won't talk about
it it's I think it's very important and
a lot of the times people forget too
that a lot of the teaching comes from
being at home right so what like I'll
use my example for existence a lot of
Korean kids that I know don't really
talk to their parents they just don't
like not even just Korean I'd say a lot
of like Asian kids that I know don't
talk to their parents like yeah they
have kind of like mom and dad kid
conversations right how are you doing
did you eat today what have you been up
to lately right and that's really where
it stops so my mom was somebody who and
is somebody who really kind of forced
his family concept right and my mom
talked about it to this day she goes
like I don't know why these people don't
talk to these kids don't talk to their
parents like how you and I taught I was
like well mom you have to understand
that we're actually very weird like
we're not the norm I was like and I
started listing off all of our family
friends right I was like these guys that
we know they're all boy families how
many of them do you know talk to their
kids like you and I stuck right I was
like I was boxing yesterday for an hour
and I just had you on speaker and we
were talking for an hour and a half on
the phone mm-hmm like who else really
does that she was that's just me and you
I was like and the reason why is because
you made it an important thing that we
connect on a personal level rather than
just mom and son it was as I want to
talk to my kid when I'm bored when I
just think about random stuff and
because you kind of it was hard at first
but you kind of develop that
relationship that's why this happened
and that's how isn't how important it is
to kind of create these great habits at
home it's how I feel I'm not a parent
yet I can only hope that I will try and
do the same but I know yeah that at home
is always where it starts and because a
teacher can come up and tell a kid like
hey you should do this isn't that right
but if the parent doesn't reinforce that
at home it doesn't [ __ ] matter yeah
it's like when you train dogs I mean I
know they train a [ __ ] dog right like
I cause I was a dog trainer for a little
bit so when I would train a dog right
and I used to always say this and even
Cesar Millan says this [ __ ] all the time
he goes we're not training a dog we're
asset training the trainer mm-hmm
there's you a dog trainer can you can go
through a whole schooling with the dog
right teach these dogs he creates great
habits if
person at home doesn't take these
happens these dogs forget things
instantly they go back to their
instincts and that's what happens like a
lot of parents don't follow up on the
stuff that's taught in school right so
put tuck me in parent cuz you know that
shouldn't should I make sure there's
food on the table it's a house or a roof
over your head I can't even get [ __ ] I
can't even imagine so you gotta give him
credit for that for sure yeah we don't
even know how we're gonna be a de parent
I'm talking about big right now there I
don't have a [ __ ] kid but who knows
right because I I had a friend - she
talked before she had her first kid she
ice on her about this [ __ ] and I still
do every time I see it because it's so
funny because of how hardheaded she is
and how opinionated she is about stuff
that she doesn't know about I'm hard I
have a hard opinion about parenting
right but like I said I'm always gonna
end it with I'm not a parent though so I
don't know I can only hope right for her
it was like these are facts so when she
said to me before she had her first kid
she goes this is what I'm going to do
she goes my kid will never watch TV or
open up an iPad until they're about 10
or 12 years old right this [ __ ] look
talk about the first year this mother
get like this I was like what happened
she goes it's hard like I'm trying to
you know eat and then you know I I can't
distract him with anything else I had to
constantly look at them if I don't get
in this iPad I'll say so so remember
when you went on Facebook and you went
on this whole diatribe trashing parents
before you were a parent right this is
what happens all right you get life
experience and you start to figure
things out yeah you found out that the
iPad isn't really for the kid just for
the parent right cuz you're trying to
just [ __ ] have a cup of [ __ ]
coffee and your kids over here grabbing
at his dick just I could put potato all
over the place you know and so she found
out like oh yeah maybe I was a little
harsh on some of these parents like I
agree with you that you shouldn't that
that as a parent I'm gonna try not to
make sure that my kids not hyper
dependent on this done like there'd be a
lot of times for it for you to say oh my
kid will never use this thing it's like
this
times have changed like this is a very
integral part of life mariya and there's
an educational stuff on this as well
like some of my kids some of my friends
kids learn how to do her ABC's super
[ __ ] early because she would play a
game on the phone right there you go so
save me time yeah so people don't we
don't we don't really know what we're
gonna do when we're parents we can only
know what happens when we're thrown into
it because I asked my mom too I was like
hey how do I become a good parent like
it when I have a
she goes you know [ __ ] knows sorry I
didn't know you survived you figure I'll
help you but even then like even if I
help you you're just gonna figure it out
as you go like you do that you're not
guaranteed to know everything when you
have a kid right yeah yeah well so you
want your kid to be bullied hell yeah
I'm be the first one to bully him do we
plug in the channeler imma [ __ ] dress
up in the big baby
grab my what happens like this [ __ ]
six-foot kid what you gonna fight him
tomorrow and then I'm gonna come back to
the playground he's gonna [ __ ] me up
oh my give your money but what happened
I defended myself you right you did like
20 years ladies you know my dad did to
me but what do i man I really hope I
didn't believe bad my worst nightmare
has to be alike hey so we're doing Maury
and you got invited because somebody
wants to talk to you about bullying it's
like a bully
I feel like I don't know if I bully per
se but I know you guys you know like
Korean people hmm
you know like Korean people like the
older hyung's would always Punk the
younger ones but it was it only lasted
for a certain amount and then you start
becoming one of us right so that was
like a hazing period I'm not sure that's
considered bullying because there's an
end goal to it it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen continuously all right
it's just like that in the beginning and
then you know you're one of us right
it's like one of those hazing things
which I which I don't think I really
like but I think I kind of did a little
bit of it but I remember back in the day
like when I used to go to a Korean
church
oh so many [ __ ] situations of just
people trying to bully somebody and the
weird thing was like I was such a fat
goofy kid like I think the whole like
bullying concept people try to bully me
all the time and they would forget like
how angry of an individual I was like I
remember this time when we were playing
basketball I'm his dude named James we
were playing at my cousin's house right
and so we were playing horse when we're
playing horse if you guys don't know
what horses I'm just
you shoot a ball if somebody falls up
and they do the same shot after so he
was just trying bully me in like the
dumbest [ __ ] way possible so we were
doing a horse and we were shooting [ __ ]
I was thrown some buckets up and it was
just me and him and then a few other
church people I already had the worst
[ __ ] a flag football day cuz it was
turkey ball for the church and we're
playing flag football the worst day ever
I was already getting yelled at by my
uncle because he expected more out of me
cousin big guy yeah I forgot how soft my
hands were yeah he was like he's like
come on like you got a [ __ ] block up
and I'm like I can't
he had me try to block this dude his
name was Shawn Lee right this guy was a
rugby player and he was like eight years
older than me I was like [ __ ] like 17
he was jacked on roids
I remember this dude hit me so hard I
flew in the air
I was horizontal and I had enough time
in the air to thing this isn't for me
man hit me really hard in the air for
that long and I landed and he was mad
that I couldn't stop this guy he's like
a roided-out rugby player so he was
screaming in my I was already having a
bad day mm-hmm we [ __ ] it let's just go
back to playing hoop so we had like you
know the church group went to my uncle's
house and so this is aids dad by the way
and so you know it's dad yeah and so
we're shooting hoops and this dude James
what was like yo I didn't shoot it from
there and he's just trying to be an
[ __ ] about right and I literally shot
from our child's I know you did show he
goes I didn't shoot her from there like
he's trying to [ __ ] Punk me forever
he's like only a year older than me I'm
a big guy he know the same height right
but I'm just fatter beefier with a short
of temper and then I goes he goes no you
got a shoe or a million shoe he goes if
you want [ __ ] play don't [ __ ]
start screaming in my face and I look at
him most like you want a [ __ ] golf
right and he's got the whole church like
the group's like what the [ __ ] I'll [ __ ]
you up right now and you know this is
like I never did this [ __ ] in church
situations because what you saw in
church David was different from what you
saw in outside David so you know like I
yeah I'm a geeky dweeby guy but I just
never liked getting bullied so if I mind
my thing was and I've said this before a
million times that you're gonna bully me
but I'm gonna be the hardest person to
bully ever so I got so [ __ ] mad
there's like this I remember the fence
I started walk I started cracking it
with my hand over and over and the
[ __ ] fence
and I started coming over towards him
and I was gonna sock this form and then
my cousin comes up to me and he grabs me
my cousin's a pastor now you know amen
calm down it's like no I [ __ ] grab
this headlight Chuck this authority and
I started running towards the minute
everybody grabbed me again and then I
just literally remember being dragged
away and I was like I'm gonna [ __ ] you
up and I go into the house I get into
the bathroom I start putting cold water
on myself to cool myself down and I'm
[ __ ] fuming and then I come back
outside and I see James out there still
outside holding a basketball just
standing there from where I was yelling
at him and I come back outside and I was
like the [ __ ] your problem he goes
Amen can I just be honest with you I
think what's up he goes I was so scared
I start dying laughing and so you meet
he's like the only thing I could think
of was like you're in front of the door
to the house and the back doors locked
I got nowhere to go I'm so sorry
early bras gonna [ __ ] knock you out
dude I was gonna knock his ass out just
because he was trying to Punk me like on
that Korean older brother shin and I was
already in a bad mood he gave me [ __ ]
yelled at by my [ __ ] uncle not today
not today [ __ ] not today but all
those like bowling instances I feel like
I wish I didn't have to go through it
but I felt like it did make me better at
dealing with situations is there any
value to that sure yeah like I feel like
it made me like stand up for myself now
and now it's not aggressive right mm-hmm
now it's like I'll stand up for myself
in a way of you know conducting myself
better like I just I won't get angry
like that anymore that doesn't happen
that's that's more if like if I get
angry smore I always turn it in a way to
make it more funny right but you know
back in the day it did save my ass a lot
because if you grew up in a very bad
area the moment somebody smelled
weakness on you you were just gonna be
that [ __ ] for the rest of the high
school year right that's it and somebody
like me who's loud and opinionated yeah
if I had to stand up for myself because
I wanted because I had a big mouth so
it's like oh he's that geeky kid but
he's a geeky kid if you put your hands
on he'll throw right back at you you
know I mean right it didn't work out all
the time I got beat up quite a few times
by a bully nerd hybrid hybrid mix it's
like he's that fat dweeby kid with
glasses but you're not gonna really like
just Punk him that easy
punching people in sort of planks yeah
yeah like yeah if I look back in high
spot I think I uh I I I'm definitely
glad that my my my dad was actually the
first one to kind of put that [ __ ] in my
head he used to say if somebody touches
you you could do whatever you want right
but just don't let somebody just take
advantage you the whole time because you
knew I was an immigrant like my first
language was Korean so you know I
already was in a disadvantage I didn't
belong in this group of people that were
just you know they spoke English
perfectly well right so it was [ __ ]
difficult no [ __ ] damn all right there
we go
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast we talked about
a little bit about bullying and we
talked about thick neck Edie
that's right man your song is Ariana
granite thank you next Oh No on to the
next one to the next favorite actor
Nicolas Cage The Closer Zegers is
favorite I'm kidding man the shoutouts
to big Edie
I'll be fine I hope you find love and
then you guys know that you catch the
genius brain podcast on all audio
platforms you catch it on YouTube but
you know most likely you're not watching
this on the road you're listening to it
so catch it on Spotify podcasts where
can they find you Khalif yeah you can
find me on instagram cliff boy holler at
me let me know if you think you find a
little TV screen seen TV screens to the
scene to TV screen Susan yeah you know
this happening full-blown actor we bout
to make it big you know I'm saying watch
out for us you know we got to be out
here to read 100 tag exclamation read
mark exclamation read Mark gang gang
gang gang yeah man that's right go see
how that species